l'argument principal qui est avancé par
l'exécutif pour justifier ce projet de
réforme c'est et bien de d'équilibrer un
système qui sera déficitaire aussi
freiner les dépenses publiques l'homme
de gauche que vous êtes que comment
réagit-il à ce projet de réforme jusqu'à
preuve du contraire aujourd'hui les
équilibré il y a il est sédentaire il
sera difficile à partir de enfin il le
sera à partir de l'année prochaine et un
petit peu plus jusqu'en 2030 jusqu'à 12
milliards je crois de ce que disait
Didier Becher bon aujourd'hui je ne vois
pas l'urgence qu'il y a justement
intervenir en plus un certain nombre
d'économistes nous disent très
clairement qu'une petite augmentation
finalement des cotisations suffirait à
combler ce déficit et revenir à
l'excédent donc je crois qu'il y a
d'autres raisons qui poussent à mon sens
le gouvernement financé d'autres projets
bien entendu peut-être dans le domaine
social mais d'autres projets que celui
des retraites aujourd'hui il y a pas
péril dans la demeure et comment vous
réagissez au premier annonces je disais
tout à l'heure là je légale qui a
atteindra 64 en 2030 alors une autre
annonce que je n'avais pas dit c'est que
l'âge de décote est maintenu ainsi à 67
ans on a pas les 72 trimestres
heureusement heureusement quand même
mais aller jusqu'à 64 ans c'était une
chose pour un certain nombre de
professions c'est peut-être pas un gros
problème mais il faut pas quand même
oublier aujourd'hui qu'en France vous
avez un quart des plus pauvres qui
meurent avant d'atteindre la retraite
avant 62 ans vous avez aussi en ce qui
concerne les travailleurs entre
guillemets ceux qui aujourd'hui
attendent leur retraite
à l'âge de aller je dirais un an avant
la retraite beaucoup ne sont déjà plus
dans le travail ils sont au chômage ils
sont en maladie ces gens-là et ben ils
sont encore un peu plus précarisés avec
ce système c'est pour ça que je pense
que là il n'est pas aussi juste que cela
d'aller jusqu'à 64 ans et d'augmenter de
cette façon là la durée des cotisations
d'ailleurs le porte-parole du
gouvernement Olivier Vérand sera demain
à Coignières il va rentrer des salariés
de l'entreprise
on en parlera probablement mais il y a
beaucoup de salariés qui sont
effectivement hostiles aujourd'hui à
cette réforme des retraites et
d'ailleurs je crois que la majorité des
français n'est pas pour alors avant de
passer à la suite et de parler des
projets 2023 à Coignières nous allons
prendre la direction de
Marnes-la-Coquette dans le département
des Hauts-de-Seine c'est à limitrophe du
département des Yvelines puisque
l'établissement public
interdépartemental Yvelines odsen
présente ses vœux ce soir c'est toi
arabe de Jordy vous le voyez on retrouve
sur place Nicolas dandry de la rédaction
de TV 78 pouvez-vous nous rappeler déjà
Nicolas ce qu'est un établissement
public interdépartemental et ceux qui
pourraient se dire ce soir du côté de
main de la coquette
[Musique]
vous savez ce basketteur phénomène qui
risque d'aller aux États-Unis l'année
prochaine jouer dans NBA donc voilà ça
se prépare il y a les répétitions qui
sont actuellement au cours et donc pour
revenir à votre question l'établissement
public interdépartemental c'est la
mutualisation notamment des politiques
et de l'insertion à travers activités
qui est une agence d'insertion à la fois
yvelinoise et alto c'est quoi naise on a
aussi la politique de la voirie de
l'archéologie ou encore de l'autonomie
pour les personnes âgées vous l'avez dit
aussi sur place des personnalités
présentes les élus bien sûr des deux
départements alors on l'évoquait souvent
il y a encore quelques années ou parler
de mutualisation par les mêmes de fusion
on allait encore plus loin entre les
départements il y a quelques années et
ce qu'aujourd'hui c'est totalement
écarté ce projet de fusion ce qu'on en
parle encore
alors il me semble que dans certains
discours dans le discours de Pierre
Bédié et de Georges Siffredi le terme
fusion sera évoqué mais aujourd'hui ce
n'est pas tellement d'actualité parce
que vous le saviez vous le savez ce
projet de fusion a été lancé en 2016
c'était pour contrer cette réforme de la
métropole du Grand Paris en gros les
départements avaient peur d'être
engloutis dans une collectivité et de
voir leur disparition et c'est pour cela
que à l'époque Pierre Bédié et Patrick
devaitdjian s'était lancé dans ce projet
de fusion donc qui date de 2016 et
aujourd'hui c'est plus des
mutualisations de services des
mutualisations de politiques publiques
au cas par cas en fonction de
si c'est efficace pour chaque chacune
des collectivités et je vais vous
prendre un exemple activité qui était
une agence d'insertion yvelinoise et ben
finalement a servi de modèle au
département des Hauts-de-Seine et
finalement c'est devenu une agence inter
départementale de la politique
d'insertion et autre exemple c'est le
passe malin c'était c'est un ce qui
permet de favoriser l'accès à la culture
pour les jeunes qui étaient un
dispositif altoé finalement et bien ça a
basculé du côté yvelinois donc voilà
finalement c'est on échange les bons
exemples les bonnes politiques publiques
les bons exemples qui a dans les
Yvelines dans les Hauts-de-Seine et ben
c'est une mutualisation des services
pour être une collectivité plus efficace
voilà où on en est alors après tout
dépendra de l'évolution
de la réforme de la métropole du Grand
Paris mais ça fait bien longtemps qu'on
en entend plus parler ça remonte avant
le covid l'utilisation de compétences et
donc mutualisation ce soir des vœux
entre les Yvelines et les Hauts-de-Seine
ça se passe du côté de
Marnes-la-Coquette merci Nicolas dandry
et merci également à Patrick Jacques de
Dixmude au moyen technique des Fisher ça
peut être dangereux les fusions moi j'ai
été élu contre une fusion celle de
Coignières mortes
aujourd'hui on mutualise un certain
nombre de choses avec Maurepas on
travaille ensemble il y a pas de souci
et on a eu interco donc il y a pas de
raison que qu'on fusionne alors veut ce
soir des Yvelines et des Hauts-de-Seine
les voeux de Coignières ce sera le 21
janvier
à la bonne date et on parlait tout à
l'heure de sobriété énergétique qui sera
au cœur aussi de cette année 2023 c'est
un terme qui est dans toutes les pensées
alors du côté de Cognard je crois qu'il
y a un plan énergétique qui avait été
décidé en novembre en novembre et qui
avait permis notamment de réduire la la
période des illuminations de Noël c'est
c'était l'une des mesures est-ce que de
nouvelles mesures sont prévues en 2021
plan assez large effectivement à plein
de sobriété d'énergie assez large qui
prenait en compte évidemment les
éclairages de Noël on avait diminué par
deux en gros la facture des éclairages
de Noël hein ça c'était clair on a aussi
bienveillé désormais à bien chauffer nos
bâtiments municipaux parce que souvent
on était quand même hors des clous hein
les 19 degrés on était plutôt à 22 23
dans certains bâtiments aujourd'hui on
est tombé à 19 on a acheté des sondes on
a acheté les minuteurs pour éteindre par
exemple et les projecteurs du terrain
beau la 22h30 aujourd'hui tous les
équipements municipaux sont éteints à
22h30 ce qui n'était pas toujours le cas
auparavant il n'y a plus une réunion
au-delà de 22h30 ce qui n'était pas le
cas auparavant
ce vont se poursuivre on a des mesures
donc j'allais dire factuel ce type de
mesure et puis des mesures structurelles
qui visent les bâtiments dans des
rénovations énergétiques évidemment
qu'on avait déjà engagés depuis
plusieurs années alors dans les grands
projets de l'année 2023 il y a plusieurs
projets de rénovation et de
réhabilitation d'abord celui du groupe
scolaire Bouvet en quoi ça va consister
c'est c'est une réhabilitation globale
d'un groupe scolaire c'est un groupe
scolaire qui date des années 70 75 il y
a jamais eu de réhabilitation c'est un
bâtiment donc ancien c'est un bâtiment
vétus de plus en plus vétuste
aujourd'hui il était nécessaire en effet
là de s'y attaquer c'était un une des
promesses finalement de notre projet
pour les années 2020-2026 alors c'est
d'abord une rénovation thermique il faut
pas la conçu comme cela comme une
véritable rénovation thermique avec une
isolation par l'extérieur avec une VMC
double flux avec une reprise des
huisseries là où elle n'avait pas été
déjà été reprise de façon justement à
limiter les consommations sont change
les chaudières on met des chaudières à
condensation et on devrait normalement
obtenir à peu près 30 à 35 % d'économies
par rapport de en consommation je dis
bien monsieur comme le prix monte on
fera peut-être pas des économies au
final mais on consomme vraiment en tous
les cas rénovation également de la
résidence autonomie des moissonneurs oui
résidence autonomie des moissonneurs
alors là aussi c'était une promesse
depuis plusieurs années en effet
c'est une résidence qui date du début
des années 80 qui est qui reste dans son
jus et il fallait effectivement refaire
très largement déjà les hollow hall
d'entrée les salles d'activité la salle
de restaurant et ensuite s'attaquer au
studio et notamment aux comment dire aux
salles de bains parce qu'on a là une
aberration pour des personnes âgées on a
une marche de de 30 cm à peu près pour
atteindre la douche donc ça c'est quand
même un véritable problème donc on
s'attaque à tout cela on va mettre des
douches à l'italienne donc il y a un
vrai vrai travail qui va être fait sur
cette résidence et je pense on en a pour
une vingtaine de mois de travaux quand
même c'est c'est un chantier colossalle
alors un enjeu aussi énergétique
important du côté d'un autre lieu de de
quoi dire inconnu c'est le théâtre le
théâtre Alphonse Daudet qui date des
années 90 qui sera également rénové
voilà le théâtre la rénovation du
théâtre la rénovation thermique du
théâtre doit commencer normalement d'ici
un mois ou deux à peu près on attend les
matériaux arrivent progressivement il y
a des problèmes à l'heure actuelle pour
se fournir en matériaux c'est pas aussi
simple que cela pour les entreprises
mais les matériaux arrivent tout le
bardage va être fait la toiture va être
isolée et on installe aussi une VMC
double flux de façon à faire des
économies de l'ordre de 30% à peu près
en ce qui concerne l'énergie sur le
théâtre on aura quand même un théâtre où
il sera beaucoup plus agréable d'aller
assister à un spectacle aujourd'hui il a
été il fait chaud à mourir et il lui
fait froid à mourir donc là on aura je
pense quelque chose de beaucoup plus
agréable pour assister aux différents
spectacles et c'est un théâtre qui est
très utilisé à l'heure actuelle
par les Coignières et mais aussi par nos
concitoyens des villes environnantes et
les autres grands projets en 2023 quels
sont-ils déjà déjà ça c'est déjà
une ville traversée par exemple quand on
prend ces trois projets c'est plus de 5
millions d'euros c'est quand même pas
rien avec aussi un axe commercial très
fort à Coignières voilà exactement c'est
quand même pas rien ensuite bien entendu
on lance la notre PLU on lance
notre PLU donc notre plan local
d'urbanisme et on lance aussi avec
Saint-Quentin qui financent une étude
sur le quartier gare et la nationale 10
justement l'idée le tal nous demande de
construire 550 logements c'est 500 à 550
logements on les construira
à proximité de la gare dans des espaces
qui sont aujourd'hui des espaces
commerciaux mais ces espaces commerciaux
sont amenés à être requalifiés et on va
dégager du foncier pour pouvoir
construire ces logements ces 500 550
logements mais comme je l'avais dit dès
le démon élection je serai pas le maire
qui va construire un deuxième poignet à
côté du premier et c'est pour cela que
j'ai tenu que dans l'étude faites par la
Communauté d'Agglomération soit prise en
compte la nationale 10 et la
requalification de la nationalité
pour l'instant il y a pas
d'enfouissement sur sur poignières trap
c'est quand même 120 millions d'euros
bon on a on a on a approché les
différentes autorités la DIRIF l'état
donc le département la région mais pour
l'instant on n'en est pas là on en est
au moins une requalification qui
permettrait de ralentir la vitesse de la
circulation sur la nationale 10 de
rétrécir les voix et donc de faciliter
la traversée parce que ça c'est un
véritable problème et peut-être
carrefour des fontaines envisager ce qui
va se faire au carrefour de la mal c'est
à dire un passage en souterrain sur le
carrefour des fontaines de façon à bien
réunir en fait la ville parce que ça
c'est une nécessité absolue aujourd'hui
c'est de la pollution c'est du danger ne
serait-ce que traversé même au feu c'est
compliqué il y a les accidents
malheureusement le maire que je suis il
y a pas si longtemps que ça je suis
quand même allé je dirais me porter sur
un accident il y avait deux morts sur la
nationale 10
centrale entre les communes de de
Coignières
c'est vraiment dans cet esprit là et
voyez qu'on travaille je dirais de façon
très mutuelle entre nos communes et
c'est vrai que c'est dans la perspective
aussi de l'évolution du quartier gare de
La Verrière les bécanes il est
nécessaire aujourd'hui
importante en fin d'année dernière
c'était le 27 novembre dernier ce drame
du jeune du jeune Gibril qui a été
assassiné après du gymnase du moulin à
vent lors d'une rixe entre bond rivale
vous étiez vous-même venu en parler ici
en visio dans notre édition et ce qui
est un travail prévu dans les quartiers
justement pour essayer d'éviter de
nouveau de tel drame bien sûr qu'un
travail prévu j'ai rencontré il y a pas
si longtemps que cela aussi le maire de
Maurepas Grégory garestier pour qu'on
puisse mettre nos équipes en synergie
pour travailler auprès auprès des jeunes
lui il va avoir des moyens
de la part du département notamment en
termes d'éducateur spécialisé moi j'ai
investi dans ce domaine là depuis des
années puisque depuis que je suis mère
on a mis on a deux on a deux deux
animateurs deux élus enfin et un
éducateur spécialisé qui travaille sur
notre quartier notamment des des Acacias
c'est évidemment pas suffisant donc j'ai
fait des demandes au département pour
aller un petit peu plus loin et on va
travailler en synergie avec Maurepas
pour nous éviter à nouveau un drame de
ce type alors travailler en synergie
c'est aussi faire un certain nombre
d'actions entre avec nos jeunes faire en
sorte qu'ils se rencontrent qu'ils se
rencontrent qu'ils puissent échanger
sans le faire à coup de marteau de
mortier d'artifice ou
avec leurs points voilà c'est ça le on a
il faut qu'on appelle évidemment cette
relation alors on sait pas trop vous
l'avez vu à cette époque là on ne sait
pas exactement pourquoi il s'est passé
cela et il s'est passé ce drame là tout
ce que l'on sait c'est qu'il y a une
forme de rivalité entre quartiers qui
existent depuis des années moi depuis
que je suis à poignée depuis 2016 j'en
entends parler
voilà et c'est très belle idée elle
continue d'exister encore aujourd'hui on
voyait d'ailleurs les images auquel vous
aviez assisté Michael midoro et c'est
vrai que le mot qui était avancé c'était
l'apaisement quand même rassemblement
la mer avait pris la parole à la fin de
cette marche blanche ça va appeler à
l'apaisement tout au long de Sonic son
discours voilà on avait tous appelé à
l'apaisement le maire de Maurepas
moi-même la mère effectivement de ce
malheureux de 14 ans il faut quand même
pas oublier qu'ils sont de plus en plus
jeunes c'est c'est ça aussi un des un
des problèmes auxquels nous sommes
confrontés aujourd'hui que tous les
éducateurs le disent aujourd'hui nous
avons des jeunes en situation de
délinquance de plus en plus jeune 14 ans
13 ans 12 ans là le meurtrier est
présumé il a 16 ans voilà on est on est
avec une jeunesse qui est perdue à
l'heure actuelle alors juste avant de
terminer cet entretien au passage à
l'interview express
[Musique]
alors le principe Didier Fisher 5
questions nous poserons les mêmes à tous
les maires qui viendront sur ce plateau
en janvier alors une exigence des
réponses courtes certaines réponses
nécessitent juste un oui un nom un pour
ou contre donc ce sera assez simple ou
pour les autres on vous demande de
répondre à les en 20 30 secondes grand
maximum et ce qu'en 2023 Didier Fisher
vous augmenterez les impôts locaux dans
votre commune alors c'est ni oui ni non
à l'heure actuelle
non c'est pas le Joker c'est à l'heure
actuelle on n'a pas suffisamment encore
de visibilité notamment du côté des
augmentations gaz électricité moi on
m'annonçait 300% pour l'électricité 500%
pour le gaz j'attends un peu j'ai fait
travailler mes services en effet aussi
sur les projets des différents services
de la commune j'attends le retour de
tout cela pour prendre une décision avec
mon équipe donc mais je l'ai déjà dit au
poignet rien vu la situation dans
laquelle les collectivités aujourd'hui
se trouvent il est difficile de ne pas
augmenter les impôts s'il y a
augmentation des impôts ça sera d'une
manière
modéré bien entendu mais vous savez les
impôts à Coignières sont excessivement
bas on nous envient côté circulation
certaines communes ont fait le choix de
passer à une limitation à 30 km/h ce que
vous êtes pour ou contre une telle idée
moi je suis pour d'ailleurs je l'ai fait
et je l'ai fait dans mon dans mon
centre-ville aujourd'hui tout le
centre-ville de Coignières est à 30 km/h
il y aura deux axes qui ne le seront pas
le boulevard des arpents restera à 50
km/h et la rue Marcel Dassault restera à
50 km/h je pense que aujourd'hui cela
apaise sérieusement la circulation dans
la ville d'autant plus que nous on est
souvent une voie de délestage de la
nationale 10 il faut pas l'oublier le
lieu dans toutes les cantines de France
est-ce que vous seriez pour ou contre
une telle obligation une incitation
peut-être une incitation moi une
incitation forte j'essaye au moins aussi
de m'y mettre tout au moins ce que je
souhaite et ce que nous travaillons avec
notre prestataire c'est d'avoir de la
nourriture effectivement de qualité et
de proximité nous sommes dans le local
le plus possible en quelque sorte pour
cette nourriture et faire travailler si
possible des agriculteurs des Yvelines
ou des départements avoisinants on a vu
dans les derniers mois malheureusement
des maires ou des élus qui ont été
victimes d'agression ou de menaces
est-ce que vous dans l'exercice de vos
fonctions vous êtes déjà senti menacé
menacé le mot et fort en tous les cas il
m'est arrivé quand je me suis un peu
attaqué à certains trafics de drogue
notamment d'être comment dire oui menacé
menacé j'ai eu des menaces sur les
réseaux sociaux des menaces qui
sentaient la mort en quelque sorte sur
les réseaux sociaux et un soir une nuit
plus exactement 1h30 du matin j'ai été
réveillé par des tirs de mortiers
d'artifice sur mes fenêtres par exemple
voilà on essaye d'impressionner le maire
pour qu'il ne le fasse qu'il ne le fasse
pas ce qu'il doit faire c'est-à-dire
empêcher effectivement ce genre de
trafic aussi dans sa ville la dernière
question est-ce que vous êtes un maire
heureux oui oui bien sûr je suis un
maire heureux et je j'ai toujours pensé
que le mandat de maire était le plus
beau des mandats et je continue de le
penser voilà merci Didier Fischer je le
rappelle mère de la commune de Poitiers
de Coignières et également
vice-président de 50 ans en Yvelines
très bonne année 2023 dans votre commune
merci et très bonne année à vous aussi
merci merci beaucoup